hello my name is Caleb Denby and welcome
back to Gabri you today on game review
we're gonna be taking a look at a game
between Veselin Topalov and Vichy and
nod from the first World Championship
match that I actually followed as a
chess player this was all the way back I
believe in 2010 back when no one knew
about chess especially not me I was
little tiny baby boy playing chess in
the 5th grade and this match
it really actually got me interested in
following professional chess it was a
fun match to watch had some very
interesting games and today we're gonna
be taking a look at one that Topalov
actually managed to win this was a
Veselin against Anant and we played or
they played rather a grünfeld not
something you see every day
in the World Championship Veselin played
Knight c3 and we have d5 C takes D and
that takes d4 Knight takes c3 B takes c3
and Bishop e7 so the main line of the
Greenfeld so far of course there's a
wide variety of ways for white to play
against the green felt in this case
Veselin chose Bishop c4 one of the most
popular lines c5 was played and now
white develops this night out - e -
rather than f3 the reason for that is
against any type of Bishop g4 move white
is now gonna respond with f3 preserving
this night so he can control more of the
dark squares in the center of the board
knight c6 from black we have Bishop e3
from white castles castles and now
Knight a5 is an ons choice in this case
and it's a pretty common way it's a
common maneuver for black just to kick
this bishop on to a less comfortable
Square in this case d3 now after b6
you'll notice this bishops kind of in
White's way here you know he doesn't
have the full support of d4 from the
Queen anymore Queen d2 is the natural
continuation for white he wants to trade
off this powerful dark squared bishop
for black this is kind of Black's key
piece in the Greenfeld in this case
anticipating that this bishop would be
traded off and not actually plays d5
challenge
these dark squares right away topalov
still plays Bishop h6 and in this case
it's actually a pawn sacrifice
let me see C takes D Bishop takes g7
King takes g7 we recapture on d4 and
black takes on d4 and now black is
simply going to be up this pawn and so
the question is well what does white
have in return for this pawn sacrifice
and the answer is the dark squares
around this King are in fact a little
bit weak and how is white going to take
advantage of those well it's with a very
natural pawn push first Derk see one
Queen d6 we see getting the stroke on
this nice open file and now white
finally continues with the move f4 and
he's simply going to push this pawn to
f5 and rip open the Kings side first
either with f6 being threatened with
checkmates incoming or with threats of F
takes G opening up more files for the
white rook in this case black chose to
respond to this with f6 and now after f5
we first see queenie 5 from Black Knight
f4 from white puts more pressure on the
g6 pawn and so black decides it's time
to move this pawn out of the way up to
g5 so we have a situation here where
Anand has for the moment kept everything
closed on the Kings side first Veselin
plays Knight h5 check King g8 and now he
tries to open things up once again with
this pawn break on h4 but after h6 we
see H takes G H takes G and once again
it's difficult to open up these files
any further for for Topalov and not has
done a great job keeping these things
locked down for the moment and there's
no way really for the white pieces to
invade we saw rook f3 in this game and
now this puts black in a pretty
uncomfortable position I've been talking
up how much anon has been doing a great
job of keeping files closed avoiding
these pawn breaks opening things up of
course when the pawn brakes don't work
and what do you go for well it's time
for those piece sacrifices and so white
actually has a very very nasty threat
here and that threat is is what
actually occurred in the game after king
f7 the way to open up the position is
with of course the move Knight takes f6
sacrificing the night ripping open the
King and actually winning the game there
is a one move only one move that keeps
the balance here for black
it's a weird looking move that you
wouldn't expect to solve the problems on
f6 it's actually some simply Bishop d7
and the point is now after these
sacrifices what you're gonna see is rook
takes f6 Queen takes g5 King f7 and by
moving this Bishop to d7 one we've
blocked off the seventh rank a bit we're
controlling some key squares using this
Bishop and we've also allowed this rook
to get back into the game and these are
the key points that make Bishop d7 the
only move for black to play the game
couldn't could continue if you try
something like h3 of course we're simply
gonna play rook g8 and after the check
will drop this Queen this King back will
drop this Bishop back as well and we'll
be controlling all of the squares around
the black king so Bishop d7 was the only
way to maintain the balance instead in
the game King f7 and now this sacrifice
is just killer King takes f6 Brooke h3
rook G it was tried of course this isn't
as good as getting another rook into the
game to defend the King though rook h6
check from Topalov king f7 rook h7 check
King eight if you play the move rook g7
we can simply take this rook and after a
move like Queen takes you're running
into Rick c7 check and after move like
king takes you're simply getting crushed
after Queen g5 so not rich g7 but king
e8 was tried running away but now simply
rook c c7 from Topalov getting more
pieces into the attack dominating the
seventh rank in front of the King and
the end is near King d8 was anons try
but now Bishop b5 controls even more
squares around this King tightens the
net and after Queen takes e4 we have the
final move of the game that forced
resignation rook takes CA check
this is simply game over for Vishy Anand
if you take with the rook you're running
into rook d7 and rook takes d4 picking
up the Queen with check and if you take
with the Queen the King you're gonna run
into queen c1 check and after you have
to block otherwise Queen c7 is mate we
can take this piece and at the end of
the day if we count the pieces white
simply has a full extra bishop and so
after rook takes c8 vishay non simply
resigned a beautiful game from Veselin
Topalov got him off to a great start in
his try for the World Championship
unfortunately for him Vichy and not
managed to pull it together and ended up
winning this match against hope alive
anyways thank you very much for joining
me for this episode of game review my
name is Caleb Denby and I will see you
next time